[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we talk
about the Higgs mechanism.
As you might know,
the Higgs boson
was discovered in 2012
by the LHC Experiment,
but the theoretical
discovery of the Higgs boson
happened much, much
earlier than that did.
In the mid 1960s, Peter
Higgs and a few others
proposed a mechanism
which gives rise
to masses of the gauge
boson, the w and the z boson.
And the Higgs boson,
or the Higgs field
then can also be used to
give masses to the fermions.
So let's have a look
at this and start
with a simple observation.
When we have written down our
Lagrangian for a simple spin
one field, gauge
field, like a photon,
we find that we want
to have local gauge
invariant for this
equation, which
means that we can
do a local gauge
transformation of our
fields, and the physics
should be unchanged of this.
So the physics, meaning that the
description by the Lagrangian,
should be invariant under
this transformation.
All right?
The problem, however,
is that, if you
want to have a spin one
gauge field which is massive,
you have to have terms in
your Lagrangian, like this one
here, where you have a
mass term for your fields.
So in general, this is not
possible without breaking gauge
invariants, and this
is a guiding principle
of our Lagrangian theory.
So this is a real bummer.
So if you want a
stopping point, so you
have a beautiful theory which
describes all the interactions,
but one important
characteristic, the masses
of the particle is missing.
But you are able to
actually do this,
not by adding specific mass term
but by breaking the symmetry,
by breaking the
local gauge symmetry.
There's various ways to do
this, and one of the ways
is to use spontaneous
symmetry breaking.
So what is spontaneous
symmetry breaking?
Imagine you have a
symmetry of rotation,
a symmetry like this pen here,
and by applying some force
on top, this pen would bend.
And by bending
this pen, it bends
in one specific direction, that
breaks the rotational symmetry.
Another way to look at this
is to just let this pen drop.
Let it go to its ground state,
lowest possible energy state,
and it will land
somewhere on the table
and by doing this
breaking the symmetry,
and it does this spontaneously.
Let's look at spontaneous
symmetry breaking
in a toy model first.
So what we're going
to do here just
add a complex scalar field and
the corresponding potential
for this field.
Potential is shown here,
and this general potential
can have multiple forms.
The first form would just
be this parabola here.
This is a solution where mu
square, this term, mu square,
is greater than 0.
In this term, there's
this unique minimum.
The minimum is here at
0, and because of that,
the mass of this field
would be equal to 0,
and the mas of our gauge field
would also be equal to 0.
But what happens now if we
have through this potential
a breaking of the symmetry?
So in this case here, the
vacuum itself, the lowest energy
state, breaks the symmetry.
You go away from the
0 point, and you're
breaking the symmetry.
So this minimum is at
v over square root 2.
v is the vacuum expectation
value of this field,
and you can simply
rewrite then this field
itself by evolving it
around its minimum.
And so you find two fields
here, this chi and this h.
The h is already kind of
pointing towards the Higgs
boson, and the vacuum
expectation value.
Now, if you add this back
into your Lagrangian--
and I'll do this again.
This is shown here, but
also on the next slide--
you can start to
identify terms which
look like mass terms
for your particle.
And the first one
is here which can
be identified as a mass
term for our gauge field.
The mass is e time v.
e times v is the strength of
the coupling of this gauge field
e times the value of the
vacuum expectation value.
All right?
So this is interesting.
So we used this new scalar
field to break spontaneously
the symmetry, and
then the mass term
appears which is
proportional to the strength
of the coupling and the
vacuum expectation value.
So the mass is generated
through the spontaneous symmetry
breaking and the
coupling to the field.
You also find a mass
term for the six field
here, for this h field.
This is not the Higgs boson.
It's just a field
which looks like it,
and so this mass term is here.
But remember that mu
squared is less than 0,
and then this chi, or the
so-called Goldstone boson,
its mass is 0.
But then we have those
terms left over here,
which we cannot really
interpret it very well.
And it's possible to remove them
by choosing a specific field.
So we do a gauge transformation
by just relabelling things,
and then the new Lagrangian
is independent of this field.
Just as a reminder, Goldstone,
the Goldstone boson,
you find those Goldstone bosons
in many places in physics.
And Jeffrey Goldstone is
a retired faculty at MIT,
so you might, in the spring
or next summer, you'll him
walking across the corridors.
So we find our new Lagrangian
which has our mass terms here,
which has a term
for the Higgs field,
and has our potential
for the Higgs field.
So this specific gauge
we just decided to use,
this so-called unitarity
gauge, and it's
important to note that the
Lagrangian itself contains
all physical particles.
But this chi, the
Goldstone boson, is gone,
and the lingo we
sometimes use here
is that the Goldstone
boson has been
eaten by the physical bosons.
And the way it has
been eaten is through
the longitudinal
polarization of this boson.
It's the equivalent of saying
that it has acquired mass.
So the pocket guys here for
spontaneous symmetry breaking
is such that spontaneous
symmetry breaking of a u1 gauge
symmetry by a non-zero
vacuum expectation
value of a complex scalar
results in a massive gauge
boson and one real
massive scalar field.
So we created mass,
but as a side product,
we also have an
additional field.
And that field itself has a
mass term, so it's massive.
The second scalar we
had just disappeared.
The Goldstone boson
has been eaten
by the longitudinal component
of the gauge field itself.
All right.
That was a simplified toy model.
Let's look at the
standard model.
So now, here, we have
to generalize from u1
to su2 or su-n gauge groups.
The scalar field is now an
n-dimensional fundamental
representation of that group
for the standard model.
That will be su2.
The gauge fields are n squared
minus one-dimensional joint
representations,
like our photon,
for example, or our
unmixed w boson field.
And the Lagrangian looks
very similar to the one we
just before with our potential.
Again, we have this
mu squared term.
We also have a lambda term here,
and then we require local gauge
invariants again.
OK.
So now, for the standard
model, again, su2
cross u1 gauge groups.
We introduce a complex field,
complex six field in su2.
It's a duplex, meaning that
it has four components.
It's complex and
has two components,
which there's a total of
four components to it.
So we already know that we
want to use m square less
than 0 for our potential to
allow for spontaneous symmetry
breaking to occur.
The minimum is then at
1 over square root 2.
0 for the upper component,
and v, the vacuum expectation,
for the lower component.
That's a choice already.
Again, why mu
square less than 0?
Because if we would have chosen
to use a positive value for mu
square, we wouldn't have
spontaneously broken
the symmetry.
OK?
So we need to have
potential which looks
like this Mexican hat here.
All right.
So now, what happens now
to our w and z bosons.
We have discussed
electroweak mixing already.
Good.
So that was the first step.
Now, we will understand
where the mass terms actually
come from.
So now, we just did the
spontaneous symmetry breaking,
and now we are looking at what
happens now if we also couple
the Higgs field to the bosons.
So again, we write
this this way,
and then we just
try to find terms.
It's really like a
mechanical writing
of the individual terms,
and you find again
terms which have a vacuum
expectation value here
and the coupling here.
And you find the coupling to
the u1 term and the coupling
to the su2 and the coupling
to the u1 term representative
to the coupling to the
original photon field
and our gauge field for su2.
All right.
The rest is rewriting
and identifying terms.
If you do this-- and this
is like a couple of pages
of writing, fine--
but if you do this, you
find, again like before,
that you find the first
and second component
of our su2 gauge field.
It gives us the charge at the
boson, the w plus and the w
minus.
And then the z
boson and the photon
mixtures of the third
component and the field b.
All right?
So these are all
physical fields,
and then we try to identify the
mass terms you find for the w.
That the w mass is
proportional or equal
to the coupling strands of
the su2 group times the vacuum
expectation value over 2.
And the mass of the
z boson is given
by both couplings times
the square root of the sums
of the square times v over 2.
OK.
If you're trying to look for
a mass term for the photon,
you find none, meaning that
the photon is massless.
And then we can look again
at weak mixing angles,
and they are now
defined directly
through the couplings in
those two gauge groups.
The masses of the
w and the z bosons
are related via this weak
mixing angle, cosine theta w.
All right.
Those elements we
already saw before.
Now, we find that the
masses of the gauge bosons
are given by
spontaneous symmetry
breaking via the vacuum
expectation value
and the strength of the
coupling of the gauge field
to the Higgs field.
All right.
So in summary, we started
with a complex scalar field.
A representation of su2 is
four degrees of freedom.
The Higgs vacuum expectation
value breaks the symmetry
spontaneously.
The w plus and w minus and
the z boson require mass,
and the three Goldstone
bosons are each absorbed
into the w's and the z bosons.
We also find an
additional scalar Higgs
boson that remains.
And so that was
the understanding
in the '60s and '70s,
and the standard model
was further developed.
And then it took us
all the way to 2012
to actually find this
new scalar particle,
the Higgs boson itself.